c'est une question d'honneur de fierté
de légitimité le berceau de la tarte
tatin c'est en sologne pour espérer
battre le record de la plus grosse tarte
tatin
il a fallu retrousser les manches trente
bénévoles an pendant 8 heures éplucher
couper en 2 500 kg de pommes gala pour
célébrer les 120 ans de la naissance de
la fameuse pâtisserie on n'a pas lésiné
sur les moyens
c'est un moule de trois mètres de
diamètre et qui pèse 730 kg bien que le
moule avec le couvercle avec le
couvercle oui tout à fait et ce n'était
que la première opération environ deux
heures
la deuxième opération c'est de poser la
pâte sur les pommes cuites
on remet le couvert on ferme le
couvercle est hermétiquement enrobé la
braise sur le couvert pour cuire la pâte
et on remet également sur le feu pour
caraméliser les pommes pour réaliser
toutes ces étapes il y allait mettre du
feu ce sont les agents de la commune de
lamotte beuvron
ils ont utilisé trois essences de bois
recyclé du boulot parce que le boulot se
consume très rapidement effets de la
bresse pas mal duchesne et de l'acacia
après mille précautions et après trois à
quatre heures de cuisson
c'est le moment fatidique l'instant de
vérité les coeurs battent la chamade
c'est le retournement on avait fait un
léger raté l'année dernière de quelques
kilos on l'avait ratée au retournement
cette année les équipes avaient répété
s'était entraîné donc on était plutôt
dans les bonnes dispositions
est ce qu'il vous reste à faire
maintenant la déguster lamotte beuvron
faisait de ce record de la plus grosse
tarte tatin un emblème de sa
reconnaissance et de sa légitimité
3 108 kg le goût de la victoire
il ya caramélisées
expulsion